hallo leute wissen kari montiert von
easyjet matthias kannst du mir einen
witz erzählen über deutsche ja also die
österreicher hätten am liebsten wenn die
deutschen touristen einfach nur das geld
überweisen würden und zu hause bleiben
werden weil ich weiter die haben das
geschafft aber wir glauben ihr könnt das
noch besser wir wollen eure witze wissen
was erzählen sich leute in eurem land
über die deutschen gibt es witze über
deutet schickt sie unbedingt schreibt
und einkommen tag und die besten sitze
werden wir demnächst vorliegen
ich freue mich drauf matthias braucht
dringend neue witze
[Musik]
[Applaus]